I mean I'm supposed to hold this thing
on me all day long
Jesus Christ yeah they have my mustache
all rolled up I looks I look this is
ridiculous
no I told him if I'm not out of here in
five minutes I'm [ __ ] walking out
yeah laughs one more [ __ ] time see
what happens okay
who's directing this [ __ ] all the way
I've always played a villain the first
time I got caught for shoplifting I had
five swatches on my wrist I like fell in
with the wrong group of people in high
school
I just like they were rich kids and and
we got caught I just I saw the guy
looking at me and I said I did it I
stole it true story
I didn't go to jail though talked my way
out of it craziest thing I ever stole
yeah kid you did did he look like you
I Cameron well you look like no no
Nicole I don't want any [ __ ] talk
that won't Jack Daniels how many times
not to say that bring it over cigarette
hey I'm Wendy we have square hamburgers
who hasn't done cocaine in this room you
can do this what [ __ ] it this is time
for me to put my pants on how do they
make you chef-worthy my twirl your
moustache that's it
keep talking already talking how much do
they pay for this why do you have that
blue scarf on the blue eyeshadow is this
something feels very there boy yeah you
are
yeah the illusion
I'm just so happy to be out of these
outfits Danny looks so stupid you so
stupid Walton right here so people are
trying to work here Walton well I've
already done my work that means I'm
faster than normal - sorry guys that
Walton Danny I'm sweating to say thank
you so much you guys the best you know I
just have to say he's found it down it
really came in a really crucial - oh
that's nice man thank you appreciate
that that wasn't on that but yeah yeah
that means so much what a [ __ ] idiot
do you want to go do some cooking I'd
love to but right before this printer
making an apple box or something Jesus
Christ thank you